So, Anthropic just silently released
this feature called Auto Dream. And
based on people's discussions, it
basically runs a sub-agent periodically
that consolidates Claude's memory files
for better long-term storage. And I saw
this tweet from Anthony here that said,
"It's pretty crazy because that's
basically how humans actually store
long-term memories is by sleeping." So,
you can see right here in this project I
was playing around with the Auto Dream.
And so, because this is still being
rolled out and it's like an experimental
feature, I tried running this right here
in my project and it is working. As you
can see, it's dreaming. Because right
here in my status line you can see that
it says dreaming and then I basically go
down and I enter it to view the tasks
and you can see what it's doing. It
starts off by saying, "Let me search for
more user feedback preferences and new
project relevant information across
recent sessions." And it's basically
looked through all of our messages and
all of our different things that we've
asked it to do. And then it gets to
phase three where it's consolidating
stuff. So, here all of the key findings
that it needs to update the memory files
with since the last time it ran. And you
can see that this is a pretty
comprehensive task. It's running for
almost 10 minutes now. It's reviewed 13
sessions and it's touching different
memory files. And basically the whole
point of this is to be an automatic
background cleanup and organization
system for your Claude memories so that
each time you start up a new session, it
feels sharp instead of kind of fuzzy or
cluttered. Now, Claude Code does already
have auto memory which lets it remember
things about your project in a memory.md
file and that usually gets injected at
the beginning of your sessions and your
conversations. And that's what allows
Claude Code currently to feel like it
understands a little bit more
contextually about what's going on. But
the Auto Dream's a little bit different
because rather than just kind of like
flooding in some information, it's
consistently compacting and pruning and
making that file better and better. It's
keeping everything feeling a lot more
fresh because it basically takes all of
this different information that goes
into your memory.md file. When it does
its Auto Dream, it merges them, it
prunes them, it refreshes them, and it
compacts things and then all of the
different memory files are a lot
cleaner. So, if I switch back into this
project, you can see that it improved
five memories. That took about 10
minutes. It improved all of these
different MD files which the project
will now be able to use and they're a
lot more clean and up-to-date. And so,
the way that you get here is you go to
memory. You can see right here
we have edit Claude memory files, and
when you open that up, you'll notice
right here we see auto dream on. This
was last ran 11 minutes ago, as you guys
just saw, and we can use  dream
to run it. Now, when you open this up,
this will be off. All you have to do is
hover over it, hit enter, and it will
change to being on. And by default, your
auto memory for your Claude will
probably already be on as well. And what
you'll notice about is that it's turned
on globally across all of your different
projects, but each auto dream has its
own files that it plays with. So, in
this other session, you can see that
auto dream is on, it last ran 11 minutes
ago, and now if I go over to my Herc 2
project, which I've never turned on the
auto dream feature, and I go ahead and
do memory, the auto dream feature's
already turned on, but you can see that
it says that it has never been ran yet.
And of course, the memory files are
different because in here I've got all
these different files, and then back in
this other project, which was kind of
more of a demo,
you can see that we only have these main
three, which are project, user, and the
auto memory folder. So, now if I'm in my
Herc 2 project and I know that my auto
dream has been turned on, it says that I
can use  dream to run. So, if I
come in here and I do  dream,
what's going to happen? It basically
just says unknown skill, and we don't
see anything going on. So, right now you
can kind of invoke this using natural
language, even though Claude code itself
might be a little confused about what
you're trying to do. So, I'm just going
to say run your auto dream, and we'll
see what it does with that information.
So, right now it says I don't have the
auto dream skill, and it's kind of
confused, but right here you can see in
the status line, we do see that it's
dreaming. And if I go down here and I
answer the tasks, we can see that it's
running this dream consolidation. It's
going to orient itself with the
environment, and then we're going to see
the list of I'm grabbing this file, I'm
looking at these sessions. And right
now, because this is a bigger project
for me, you can see that it's reviewing
285 sessions. So, this will probably
take longer than 8 to 10 minutes. So,
while we're letting this run, let's talk
a little bit more about why this
matters. So, obviously this just came
out, and I haven't had time to really,
really test it and see if it's worth it
or not, but based on what I'm seeing, I
definitely think it is. And let's talk
about why that is. So, the first big
point is that you have less repetition.
Even with auto memory, I still feel like
sometimes I'm re-explaining things, or
I'm trying to, you know, carry over
context from one session to another, and
less repetition is obviously a good
thing. Another thing that we have that
kind of floats behind the scenes is less
bloat, because part of the system is
that it's compacting and pruning stuff.
Pruning basically just meaning like
eliminating things that are unnecessary,
trimming the fat. And when we're getting
rid of all of that excess fat and excess
tokens, it obviously helps us with our
bloat and helps us with our context
management. We also have better recall,
because it's getting rid of things that
we don't actually need, it's easier to
find things. So, just picture an example
of like, you know, you've got 100
different balls in a ball pit, and
you're looking for one pink one out of
all the blue. Well, what if we take away
half of the blue, it's going to be
easier to find that pink. And then, what
I think is really cool is it's basically
just like sleep. So, whatever cadence
that this runs on, which we'll talk
about a little bit later, when it hits
that point, it basically just resets.
So, it's like a checkpoint. Every time
you get to a new checkpoint, you're
basically saving yourself. So, before,
it would have all of these different
files, right? You'd have these huge,
bloated context files, MD files, but
now, auto dream takes all of that and
just keeps the important information
that you need, which may only be, you
know, a couple different bullet points,
rather than having hundreds of lines.
So, the way that it actually works is
step one, once it's activated, it will
gather session info. After that, it will
read the current existing memory files,
and then, it will load it into a sub
agent, which does the actual dream
prompt. So, I don't know for certain,
but I'm imagining that the dream prompt
is something like this. You are
performing a dream, a reflective pass
over your memory files. Synthesize what
you've learned recently into durable,
well-organized memories, so future
sessions can orient quickly.
Keep
under a line limit, it's an index, not a
dump. Link to memory files with one-line
descriptions, do not copy full memory
into it. After it's ran that prompt, it
goes through the consolidation and
pruning, which like I said, is just
cleaning things up, and then it goes
ahead and it stores all of the results.
And then, whenever it wakes up the next
time to do a dream, it basically just
repeats that process every time. So,
once you have auto memory turned on and
auto dream turned on, how does the auto
dreaming actually take place besides you
invoking it with  dream or
telling it to? Well, basically two
different types of triggers. Or both. It
could be based on hours, which means
like, "Hey, every 12 hours I'm just
going to do my auto dream." Or it could
be based off of sessions. So, maybe once
you hit 300 sessions, it automatically
does a dream. Now, this isn't confirmed
with official documentation. This is
just basically what it seems like after
some ex discussions and some Reddit
discussions, but just keep that in mind.
That is likely how this works, but I
don't know for certain. Now, once that's
running, you'll basically be able to see
a couple different statuses. You can
either see that it's running, you can
see that it's never ran before, you can
see when it was last ran, or you can see
basically just nothing and it will be
idle. And what's important to know here
is that it's only going to touch memory
files. As you guys saw in that first
example, it said I updated five files.
Those were all context files. So, all of
these right here that said I improved
five memories, all of these are MDs.
None of these are code or scripts or
anything like that. So, how do we think
about the different layers between these
different types of, you know, systems
within Cloud Code? So, for normal
sessions, we basically just have the
ability to code, to debug, to refactor,
to, you know, talk to Cloud Code. Then
in the middle, we have that auto memory,
which records decisions, patterns,
important things about the actual
project or about you. But there's not a
great method for cleaning that up
consistently unless you Frankenstein'd
your own solution to do that. So,
basically what auto dream does is in the
background, without you having to
manually go in there and prompt it to,
looks through everything, cleans
everything up, and fixes a lot of stuff.
And so, that's why having these three
layers work together, it creates a
really powerful system that likely is
going to help you scale better and keep
all of your sessions feeling cleaner and
way more like a human who can remember
things about you rather than, you know,
a chatbot. So, So has been running now
for over 6 minutes. I'll just check in
with you guys when this is done and we
can see what memory files it went ahead
and updated. So this one actually only
took 8 minutes, which was interesting,
even though it had to look through way
more sessions, 285 compared to about 13,
but it was able to update these three
different memory files. And you can now
see that there are no background tasks
currently running. And if you want a
little bit more visibility, you can see
what it actually did explicitly. So it
added these couple entries and it
removed these sections. And now if I
wanted to restore those or add some more
insights, I could and I could also go
view the file, of course, if I wanted to
make sure that it was all accurate. And
the cool thing about this is as you use
the Auto Dream more and more, it's going
to get better and better at
understanding what type of context is
important to you and what is not. But
anyways, that is going to do it for
today. So if you guys enjoyed the video
or learned something new, please give it
a like. It helps me out a ton. And as
always, I appreciate you guys making it
to the end of the video. I'll see you on
the next one. Thanks, everyone.